عسكرية امريكية في جيبوتي شرقي
افريقيا للاستعداد والتأهب
للغاية. وقد بدأت بالفعل الكثير
من الدول اجراءات اجلاء جالياتها
كيربي منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجية في مجلس الامن
لم تقف صامتة بل هددت باتخاذ ضد
طرفي الصراع السوداني. هنا جون
البرهان والبدء في عملية التحول
الديمقراطي. كما اكد حميدتي ان
اضاف قائلا لا نعلم مكان حميتي
لكنني موجود حاليا في مركز قيادة
العمليات العسكرية في السودان هو
التخلص من قائد الجيش عبدالفتاح
المسلحة للتفاوض اذا انسحبت قوات
الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم
السودان من اجل الطموح الى
الحكم. وابدى البرهان استعداد
وحربهما الاعلامية. حيث اتهم
رئيس مجلس السيادة السوداني
النازحين السودانيين الذين فروا
الى دولة تشاد المجاورة عشرين
الاف ومائتي جريحا بينهم خمسون
طفلا. بينما يرجح ان يكون عدد
العالمية تؤكد ان عدد القتلى
المدنيين في السودان تجاوز
تتوقف رغم سريان الهدنة واندلعت
في احياء الصحافة والجبر والدرجة
بناء على تفاهمات دولية واقليمية
ومحلية حسب ما ورد في بيان
المسلحة على الهدنة التي تسري
اعتبارا من الجمعة. فانه تم رصد
الجيش السوداني لمدة ثلاثة ايام
اعتبارا من الجمعة لتمكين
المواطنين من الاحتفال بعيد
الفطر وانسياب الخدمات
لكن من بين الظلام ينبثق نور وان
كان بسيطا. هدنة جديدة اعلنها
المدنيون ترتفع اعدادهم.
والسودان في طريق الى نفق مظلم.
الامريكان فاصحاب العيون الضيقة
لا يلعبون. السودان يلفظ انفاسه
ان لهم مآرب اخرى من تحركاتهم
العسكرية؟ هذا ما سنعرفه في
فهل سيكتفي الغربيون فقط بنقل
رعاياهم العالقين في السودان ام
من السودان وسط تكهنات متزايدة
بانها قد تشارك في نوع من
الجارديان البريطانية ان قوات
امريكية وبريطانية تنقل بالقرب
التكنولوجيا احد اساليب مواجهة
القوى الغربية. فيما لم تفصح
استخدمتها في الحرب الاوكرانية.
بكين لم تنف الخبر لكن تعتبر
سلاحا سيبرانيا جديدا يمكنه
السيطرة على اقمار العدو
لاجلاء ستين مواطنا اسبانيا
عشرين مدنيا من دول اخرى. فيما
انه يجب الا يتوقع المواطنون
الامريكيون في السودان عملية
بترتيب الاجراءات اللوجستية
لاجلاء رعاياها من السودان. فيما
الاوكران? الصين تتفوق على
روسيا. بعد اعتراف واشنطن بكين
قوات الدعم السريع تلقت اتصالات
من كل الاطراف بما في ذلك
عليها في المجالات التقنية.
اليوم امريكا تعترف بتفوق الصين
قوات الدعم السريع في السودان
محمد حميدتي ان الهدف من
العام لجامعة الدول العربية
والامين التنفيذي للهيئة
لاجلاء الرعايا الامريكيين حال
الاضطرار لذلك في السودان مقلق
القومي الامريكي يصرح ان
الولايات المتحدة ستنظر في
لاجلاء الرعايا الكوريين حالما
يسمح بذلك. بينما افادت صحيفة
عبدالفتاح البرهان قيادة الدعم
السريع بالتسبب في الاقتتال في
اسبانيا فقد اعلنت ان طائراتها
جاهزة وتنتظر الظروف المناسبة
والولايات المتاخمة لمناطق
الاشتباكات. لكم الله يا ابناء
والتزمت بالوضع الذي كان قائما
في ديسمبر الماضي. واستبعد
القوات. الاشتباكات العنيفة بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع لم
من المدن السودانية. اوروبا تفر
من السودان. حيث بدأت باريس
قال نائب المتحدث باسم وزارة
الخارجية الامريكية فيدينت باتيل
الجيش ولن اتركه الا على نعشه.
وجميع مطارات السودان تحت سيطرة
يستعد الجيش الكوري الجنوبي
لارسال طائرة عسكرية الى قاعدة
السودان على وقف القتال. مضيفا
ان الرئيس بايدن وجه الجيش
الاجلاء او انقاذ الرعايا
الغربيين المحاصرين في البلاد.
اجلاء سريعة نظرا لاغلاق الخرطوم
والوضع الامني غير المستقر. اما
الوضع شارك الامين العام للامم
المتحدة انطوني غوتيريش في
الانسانية. وقال الجيش السوداني
انه على الرغم من موافقة القوات
اجتماع افتراضي مغلق جمعه مع
رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي والامين
يعني ذلك ان لا فائدة من النووي
دون التوجيه من القمر الصناعي
الحكومية الدولية المعنية
بالتنمية ومنظمات اخرى ذات صلة
صحة قرار روسيا حول العملية
العسكرية في اوكرانيا. واضاف
الجيش مسؤولية فشلها. بالانتقال
للجهود الدولية الساعية لتهدئة
وخمسين مستشفا عن العمل من اصل
اربعة وسبعين في العاصمة الخرطوم
الجيش عدا مطارين. رد الطرف
الاخر جاء سريعا حيث قال قائد
الف شخص. ليس ذلك فحسب بل واعلنت
نقابة الاطباء السودانيين اثنين
السودان. لنعد رأسي حربة الازمة
السودانية البرهان وحميدتي
مجموعة من الادوات والخيارات
لاجبار الطرفين المتصارعين في
الامريكي بارسال وحدات عسكرية
للتمركز بالقرب من السودان
لمناقشة التطورات في السودان.
امريكا من ترى نفسها شرطي العالم
الولايات المتحدة والاتحاد
الافريقي لتعزيز الهدنة لكنه حمل
العديد من الانتهاكات التي قامت
بها قوات السريع. وكانت قوات
فتاكة ونحن نتحدث عن وثائق سرية
مسربة. بل تحموا انفسكم ايها
البرهان اي حوار مع حميتي وقادة
الدعم السريع حاليا. البرهان
بعد ان تنهيها الحرب؟ الرد
الروسي جاء برسالة من بوتين نفسه
الجديد تحديد ما يسمح بتصديره
الى روسيا وفق وكالة كيودو
بيرج ان جميع حلفاء الناتو
اتفقوا على ان تصبح اوكرانيا
العدو في الظلام لكن مهلا كيف
تمتلك واشنطن قدرات سيبرالية
الاولى جنوب العاصمة الخرطوم حسب
مصادر اعلامية. ومثل كل النزاعات
يذهب المدنيون ضحية لصراعات
الجبابرة. هنا منظمة الصحة
الحسبان. ان اي هجوم نووي لن يتم
الا عن طريق الاقمار الصناعية.
صوب الهدف المراد تدميره. اذا
فما فائدة السيف وانت ستقاتل
ايام الحرب. وهذا السلاح يفوق كل
قدرات روسيا السيبرانية التي
الاتراك سعوا لتجنب رد فعل
محتمل. فما الذي تحضرون له ايها
السيبراني. فقد كشفت وثائق
امريكية سرية ان الصين طورت
اربعمائة قتيل بينهم تسعة اطفال.
فيما بلغ عدد المصابين ثلاثة
بالمسلمين الروس وطمأنهم بانه
سيهتم بتعاليم الاسلام خاصة في
للاسلام الذي يحترم العادات
والتقاليد الابوية واشاد
في سوريا بمساعدة كردية واشارت
الوثائق السرية التي نشرتها
الدعم السريع في السودان اعلنت
موافقتها على الهدنة الانسانية
واشنطن بوست الى ان تركيا كانت
على علم بالمخطط وان المسؤولين
الاخيرة. الوضع في السودان يزداد
توترا والمعارك تتوسع والضحايا
واشنطن اذا ما كانت تمتلك قدرات
مماثلة. معلومة يجب ان نضعها في
الاوكرانية عدت مخططا سريا
لتنفيذ هجمات ضد القوات الروسية
اوكرانيا للحلف واوكرانيا تنتقم
من بوتين في سوريا وتركيا تنقذ
روسيا والصين تتدخل بينما الناتو
يعلن عن موافقته لانضمام
روسيا. وفي ظل سيطرة قوات روسيا
على مناطق جديدة في باخموت حسب
الدفاع الروسية. في الجانب الاخر
اوكرانيا تبحث عن طرق للهجوم على
قايلن ان حلف الناتو يظهر طبيعة
عدوانية تجاه روسيا وهو ما يثبت
بيسكوف ان انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الناتو سيشكل خطرا كبيرا على
المدارس الروسية ليلحقه المتحدث
باسم الكريملين ديمتري بسكوف
الايام القادمة.
الصناعية وشلوا مهمات التواصل
والمراقبة الاستخباراتية خلال
صحيفة واشنطن بوست عن وثائق سرية
مسربة ان الاستخبارات عسكرية
القوات الروسية لكن اين? ليس في
باخموت بل في سوريا. حيث نقلت
استخدام دبابات ابرمز وصيانتها
في الاسابيع المقبلة. حيث تواصل
عضوا في الحلف في نهاية المطاف.
اتقصد ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا
الى روسيا وسيتعين على الدول
المشاركة في نظام العقوبات
للمسلمين هنأهم فيها بحلول عيد
الفطر المبارك مؤكدا احترامه
لاوكرانيا هنا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لواد اوستن يعلن ان
الامريكية بالمانيا لتنسيق تسليم
الاسلحة والمعدات الاخرى
ننسى ايضا ان الصين تستنسخ اي
شيء ومخازن الاسلحة الامريكية
تدرس مجموعة الدول السبع الكبرى
فرض حظر شبه كامل على الصادرات
تسريع جهودها لادخالها الى ساحة
المعركة في اقرب وقت ممكن. بما
اكبر دليل. لنكمل ومن جهته قال
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ينسون
للانباء. اسمحوا لي بالتدخل هنا.
ان روسيا تتحالف مع الصين ولا
الولايات المتحدة ستبدأ تدريب
القوات الاوكرانية على كيف
العسكري لاحد اطراف الصراع لا
يجتمعان. وخلال اجتماع لقادة
الدفاع من جميع انحاء اوروبا
والعالم في قاعدة رامشتين الجوية
الغربية للسلام خالفت ذلك
بافعالها. فالسلام والدعم
حدود السودان لتلحقه بريطانيا
وفرنسا. واشنطن تناقض نفسها.
تطلب المساعدة العاجلة. البرهان
وحمتي لا للحوار وامريكا تتدخل
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية ما
زالت مستمرة كلما دعت القوى
لتمطرهم بالعقوبات وبايدن يوجه
القوات العسكرية بالتمركز في
فما هذا السلاح؟ والسودان يلفظ
انفاسه الاخيرة القتلى يرتفع
بشكل مرعب متجاهلا الهدنة
المعلنة والمستشفيات السودانية
الموقف. امريكا تحذر من سلاح
صيني يتفوق على السلاح النووي.
ودبابات واشنطن تتحضر لدخول
اوكرانيا والدول السبع تخنق